former vice president Mike Pence's
slamming former president Trump for his
actions on January 6. in particular a
reckless tweet sent at a time when Pence
was hiding from the mob as they chanted
that they wanted to hang him face a
nation moderator Margaret Brennan spoke
to Pence about his former boss and why
Mike Pence still won't testify on what
happened that day
you had such an eyewitness view sir for
four years you have the credibility to
say to the American public whether there
is a risk or not of him being
commander-in-chief well
Margaret look we
January 6 was a tragic day I've been
very clear as I am in my book that
the president's words and actions
in and around January 6 were Reckless
the tweet that he issued the day that I
was in the loading dock before the below
the United States Senate
endangered my family and endangered
people that were in the capitol
and was indefensible the idea of
relitigating the 2020 election continues
to circulate as you know that amongst
members of your party do you think that
continuing to push these claims as the
former president does
is a direct threat
the 2020 election was not stolen we have
a process in this country
where States conduct elections
questions of irregularities are fraud
are then adjudicated in the courts the
states then certify electoral votes
and as we did on January 6 in the wake
of that terrible violence the role of
the Congress is to open and count those
votes and to certify the election we did
that and Joe Biden was elected president
of the United States of America I want
to ask you though
do you intend to ever sit and answer
questions written in person for the
January 6 committee I served for 12
years in the Congress it's inconceivable
to me that one party would appoint every
member of a committee in Congress that's
antithetical to the whole idea of the
committee system that being said I never
stood in the way of senior members of my
team cooperating with the committee and
testifying
but Congress has no right to my
testimony you're closing the door on
that entire area I'm closing the door on
that
Margaret Brennan joins us now I'm so
fascinated by what the vice president
has to say because he still doesn't seem
willing to just totally condemn a
full-throated condemnation of Donald
Trump this was your this was your
running mate your partner and he's
encouraging people basically to kill you
he could have been killed that day I
really do believe that well Gail I I
asked this question to the former vice
president about 10 different ways to
make exactly that point your daughter
your wife your brother we're Sheltering
and someone uniquely positioned to talk
about that day and Mike Pence is very
careful here I want to make sure that we
point out that the January 6 committee
does have two Republicans on it
Republican leaders chose not to appoint
more but in condemning the actions and
calling the former president Reckless
and saying he was part of the problem
these are all things he said to me it's
going right up to the line without
completely separating from the part of
the Republican party that's very
supportive of the former president the
Trump True Believers we called them on
Election night is that why you think
he's reluctant because I I I think
everybody would understand if you if he
just said I am very angry this was very
dangerous I'm very hurt by this and very
disappointed in the way I was treated
because he was very loyal to Donald
Trump he was and he still says to this
day I am angry but and it took him two
years to say this so this is going
farther
um and you know we have a number of
exchanges about that but I made that
point I was like if
I think most parents would say if my
child was in the midst of this how could
you not be full of Rage he said I had to
move on and deal with the functioning of
the country but this is going to be a
challenge for him and for other
Republicans seeking the nomination
potentially in 2024 where they have to
thread this needle of separating from
Trump the man from trumpism the movement
which is a force within the party yeah
it's a fascinating conversation it
includes more than just January 6 that I
know we'll see on Face the Nation on
Sunday Margaret thank you you can see
more of Margaret's interview with former
vice president Mike Pence including his
reaction to the overturning of Roe v
Wade that Sunday on Face the Nation